uh mrs mehtil verstappen
to
discuss with utra committee members
the
energy winter preparedness once again i
would like to thank
the deputy director general for being
with us today for this exchange of views
uh
focused mainly on the
energy winter preparedness plan
presented in july we
didn't have the chance to discuss in the
committee and you know well that the
council the energy ministers agreed on
amended version already on 26th of july
but
i would like to thank the european
commission for
the informal briefings offered to the
parliament technical staff at the time
of the discussions and adoption of this
measure also i had the chance to to
discuss with the colleagues from uh
european commission from dgnr and to
understand exactly uh what was the
initial intention and what are the
final decisions of the
council of the 26th of july
of course
i'm sure that will be extremely
interested to hear from mrs werder for
something about the emergency tool for
the electricity
market the commission intends to present
in the coming days as well as on its
longer term work
on electricity market
design because there is a huge
expectation to to do something on the
electricity price in my opinion the
marginal price methodology is obsolete
we have to re design to rethink because
the markets are here to serve the
consumers and if the consumers
are not happy then we should intervene
but of course let's see what european
commission intends we have approximately
one hour at 10 o'clock
we scheduled the votes
we have a full list of interventions i'm
afraid we cannot take hdi and i go
directly to the deputy director general
mrs versterfer to
make to ask her kindly to make the
opening statement
good morning and uh thank you mr busan
mr chair and good morning to all members
of the european parliament i'm pleased
to be here right after summer
for those who had a
short summer
and we are back
and i'm pleased to be back and give you
an update on what
is an important element of our winter
preparedness
obviously the situation uh remains very
very critical and from the european
commission side we are working full
speed now again since month but now
again
on looking at the different aspect of
security of supply and energy prices
so
i will concentrate now my presentation
on the winter preparedness package
you got a briefing for my colleague just
before summer on the technical briefing
but i'm pleased to do it here now
in the parliament
so the situation remains
quite critical there is a risk of
disruption
which is very strong even getting
stronger as already half of our member
states are affected totally or partially
by disruptions and as a result of that
13 member states are either partially or
fully cut off from russian gas
and as you know
russia not stream one
is since yesterday 31st of august for
three days in maintenance so there is no
gas flows from
russia to germany and the rest of europe
since yesterday on north stream one and
we are also looking at the impact of
that
there's one good news in all that that
is the storage the gas storage filling
the eu average is eight eighty percent i
remember we had a discussion also on our
proposal on the gas storage it was a
fast track procedure within the
parliament we're very happy and since
yesterday we are at 80 percent average
you feeling some member states are above
some are still at between 60 and 70 but
in the transit trajectory so this is
good news to help us prepare for this
winter
we have also uh
continued
on the wepower which remains
this key strategy of the european
commission with his part on
diversification so we are really
diversifying
away from russia and by either we have
higher lng and higher pipeline imports
from alternative suppliers us norway
algeria azerbaijan and we are looking uh
and exploring the appropriate legal
tools to make joint purchasing happening
happening
then also not to forget i will highlight
it
that we are also accelerating renewables
deployment is a very very important
aspect and energy efficiency so these
key we come back to that in parliament
uh very very soon on the ed and the red
two this is top priority even more so
now to have ambitious and
accelerated
work but it's not enough to look at the
supply side that's why we want to
complement the work and we need to
reduce gas demand and we need to start
making more savings as soon as possible
not only to increase the injections and
storage and more generally to strengthen
our preparedness for the next winter
that's why the european council asked
the commission to propose an eu
contingency plan and we
adopted on 20th of july this new
council regulation and also the plan of
demand reduction which was agreed in
rapid time again on the 26th of july and
entered into force on the 8th of august
the new regulation is about orderly and
coordinated reduction of gas consumption
across the eu to prepare for the
upcoming winter
if we reduce our gas demand proactively
this allows us to avoid washed or
unilateral decisions when it is too late
it is possible to plan the savings in
the most efficient way and minimizing
the impact as much as possible on people
and business and if we do it now the
impact on gdp is relatively smaller if
we save now we have proposed a two-stage
approach so preemptive action now and
the union alert
we asked member states to reduce demand
voluntary by 15
starting from the 1st of august still
end of march which is the gas winter if
so if i it's based on calculations we
did
with nzg and other institutions so that
the 15
is according to
already quite uh higher than average
winter colder than average winter what
is needed to reduce demand
if the reduction is not enough and we
are monitoring that closely we expect
first reports from member states but in
october and we are in obviously daily
contact with the member states to look
at the measures but if it's not enough
there is the possibility to trigger a
union alert which is a mandatory
obligation for the member states to meet
the 15 percent gas reduction target
it will be the member states who are the
in control over the triggering of an
eventual union alert that was decided at
the energy council on the 26th of july
so it's not the commission it's a
decision by and the union alert
can be only triggered or activated by
the council
as decided on the 26th of july
it's very difficult to predict the
winter depends on whether and
what what are the volumes of alternative
gas supplies and so on but this is an
important very important step and i
think we need to be clear that such a
proposal
has been adopted in the council in
record time by 27 member states is
really we have never seen that so
there's a solidarity to the reduced 15
percent and that corresponds to the 45
psm bcm of gas needed to be saved as i
said since beginning of august until the
end of march
the council endorsed the target level
but they have introduced some
flexibility for some member states it's
clear that some member states are more
hit those who are closer to russia
central and eastern european countries
or those who have a higher gas share but
and that's why there are some
exemptions in the rules which were
agreed in the council for example for
those who are not well interconnected or
islands
portugal spain island but also others so
that was
the flexibility given to the specific
situation of the member states but
overall
we are in line of the 15 percent target
and that the
achieved
it's
based on also guidelines which we
adopted in addition to the regulation so
these guidelines help member states and
support member states in reaching the 15
percent of reduction and we have already
started to identify some good practices
for member states who have started to
implement it
either by measures to cut
lights or some other heating proposals
in offices and we see this is a
development not only in spain and some
other parts but negotiations are ongoing
also in many of the member states and we
are in close contact with them and we
are sharing those good practices of
market-based and non-market-based
demand-side measures that can be taken
in order to free up gas volumes already
today
the parliament was not
formally involved because it's an
article one two two which is the
regulation basis but we of course and my
commissioner is fully committed to
inform and continue to inform the
parliament so thank you very much for
your attention i close here and i'm
looking forward to your questions thank
you
thank you thank you so much once again
uh thank you for keeping us individually
updated uh and uh even that would like
always to
have a role for the parliament as the
parliament is the
uh result of the direct vote of the
citizens of course it was a very uh
emergency situation and
i we also
we also see very positively the fact
that the council the energy ministers
mobilized
quick during the summer let's see how
many member states will really implement
the voluntary plan because it's not
clear yet for us
and uh let's see if the alert mechanism
will be triggered uh
at the end of the year those who are not
started to reduce consumption
how they will uh how they could fulfill
the 15 reduction because it will be very
challenging but maybe these questions
will come also from colleagues once
again thank you for presenting the plan
and thank you for keeping us
informed and
discussing uh all the details with the
ita committee of european parliament i
go now to the coordinators round
two minutes for each intervention please
and i start with the epp coordinator mr
christian miller
thank you very much and welcome back
after the summer
for the epp group the solidarity with
countries um
is
which are most dependent on the russia
remains one of the crucial elements and
you have been referring to solidarity to
quick
decisions but at the same time we should
not forget to look forward
i mean if you look to the investment
package there is not a single
transnational
energy project
there's no not a single to invest in a
gas pipeline between the
iberian peninsula in western europe
there's no single transnational attempt
to send price signals by investments to
the markets
and that's worrisome that doesn't fit
together this 500 billions are almost
wasted for the fight we are fighting
right now
and there is no single from the member
states and there is no critical
reflection from the commission so far on
how the money has been spent there's a
lot of money not spent yet
there will be a lot of member states not
being able to spend all the money
and we really should look forward to
investments transnational investments in
hydrogen infrastructure
in hybrid infrastructure gas and
hydrogen in ports
in supply chains
if we don't send these price signals
the markets will react like they react
they panic um they price in
and we we are confronted um with the
social disaster as a consequence of the
crisis which is unforeseen yet
so as the chair had been rightly saying
regarding the solidarity agreement
i would like to know if there is are any
more agreements or just eight countries
covered by the six agreements so far
including
between germany and austria estonia and
latvia italy and slovenia
and i think in more general terms i mean
that is also your perspective i mean
what we see is that we are lack of
deepening of the energy market in europe
it's still a disaster i mean we are
coming from the early 2000s where most
of the legislation had been based on
environmental law because we need we
didn't have that in the treaties
but so far we didn't see any signals of
the deepening of the energy market in
europe
and its individual initiatives between
portugal now doing contracts with the
port of rotterdam to deliver hydrogen
but there is no coherent strategy and my
basic question in terms of investment
and what we could do is what you
consider to be possible to use the 500
million we spent in the investment plan
in terms of deepening the infrastructure
building up the infrastructure leading
from gas infrastructure to then the
needed hydrogen thank you very much
thank you so much the snd coordinator mr
danika
thank you so much dear chair it's nice
to see all of you there quality thank
you so much general director
so
extraordinary times extraordinary
measures otherwise we'll be witness in
the so called the funeral of the eu
economy this winter just put it this way
so my question to you is are you ready
to take some concrete measures for the
in order to prepare this winter so to be
better prepared
like
taxation of the wind for profit of the
market operators who have excessive
the benefits for the emergency situation
and to use these resources to better
address the vulnerable consumers and the
smes
two
suspending transactions on the spot mark
in case of excessive price fluctuation
general director
the small market was designed to address
the percent of the total market uh for
gas for instance and now is 50
so why we should accept that 50
on the so-called spot market which is
based on the speculation and total lack
of transparency
it's actually it is still acceptable
and why do we accept to have long-term
contracts based on the prices on this
very spot market
with no transparency
no full disclosure of who are the
shareholders
what are the prices what is their
acquisition price prices and what is the
consumer prices
number three
why you don't have a commodity exchange
for gas for instance and why we don't
link the gas price we foil as it used to
be
why because the flotation of the oil is
not so
on the excessive limits and that will
calm the prices so on the gas
that will be another question
imposing limits on the reselling
commodities
a number of intermediaries is it true
that on the this chain between the
those making the acquisition of the gas
and the consumer they can be as much as
10 intermediaries just to be sure that
the price is
the increase from let's say 100 euros
the price from norwegian gas to 3 000
euros
and who is making that money
from 100 to 3 000 euros
number five
thank you
why
i don't have to please the time is uh
but please miss
the last question the last one
introducing a cab based on the prophet
the margin i think that if you make like
10 percent which is the average in the
eu economy it will be also acceptable
for the energy companies
across the the whole chain and that will
be very much welcome for all of uh by
all of us and thank you so much
thank you so much mr nicano the
questions were very interesting and uh
thank you uh on behalf of renew group we
have mr grootler his uh
remote
remotely and
no translation so
please
don't worry i will speak in english dear
chair dear mrs
what's the offer it's nice to see you
again
thank you very much for coming giving me
the floor
i would like to focus my time on energy
prices which is the biggest internal
crisis the the eu is facing today
it affects our industry our growth and
especially our citizens
who are worried for their bills
i would like to thank the commission for
for the massive work done
since the energy market outbreak
but today the eu needs to act now on the
electricity prices
on the short term
we need develop an energy shield to cap
at the electricity price
president van vandalian manson
this option and i hope it will be
included in
our
in your proposal sorry uh will you also
propose concrete actions for the longer
term
for instance the decoupling of
electricity on gas prices
also we need
a strong solidarity between member
states
while gasprom has decided to stop
supplying us to ng for example
hungary
hungary just sign an agreement with them
how to ensure that the eu will act
collectively to solve this crisis on get
rid of the russian gas will there be
actions for the commission
if this solidarity is not respected
thank you very much
merci beaucoup
i would like now to invite on behalf of
the greens mr bloss
thank you very much and good to see you
all again even though it was a
difficult summer and i think it will be
even more difficult um fall and winter i
think we we not only now have a capacity
problem we really have a price problem
it's impossible for citizens to pay 500
euros maybe some or even thousand euro
more per month
for energy so we really have to focus on
this and at the same time um fossil
companies make huge profits so i really
uh
support also what mr nika said in terms
of windfall profit tax and i wonder if
you are planning something also in this
direction also for the european level
um
i'm looking to the next energy council
um i think it is important to understand
also that the
common purchases platform is not really
working because still
member states companies in europe are
trying to secure gas for themselves and
and push the prices up so we need to
have
some mandatory um common purchases for
europe to bring prices down um
um and do to cut the price down and
that's kind of like a buyer's cartel and
what what is needed
because we see that the prices are so
much higher for instance than in asia
that this is basically a bubble so are
you planning something in this direction
and
thirdly
um
as i said for citizen system is it's
impossible to pay for the energy price
for some of them i think we need
something like a basic contingent of
cheaper energy
for for citizens and everything that is
above this basic contagion can be
expensive as it is right now but this
has to be ensured that
no house will be cold in winter because
they cannot afford it anymore are you
planning something like this will you
plan to um
to put a moratorium on gas and energy
cuts um and
lastly i think um it's important that
even if you put this
rule i think 177
that you really inform the parliament
keep us informed regularly and
also in a in a structured manner so i
wonder how you will do that because
uh in the the last things we i only have
found out via
via the press so it's important to keep
us involved thank you very much
thank you chair thank you mr
swordsdorfer and uh welcome back to
colleagues uh well over the past month
the eu adopted a two-fold strategy to
deal with the gas shortage emerging
focused on
the gas storage regulation and the gas
reduction plan
on paper the strategy seems to be
working according to the most recent
data european gas deposits are 80
percent
full on average with some member states
being ever had scheduled
in in the feeding process
in combination with the
15 percent gas reduction plan gas
deposits are expected to avert a winter
supply crisis and still have gas
left after the 2023 winter
however
uh
these measures alone one accessory will
not be sufficient to avoid certain costs
for businesses and households
and avert the risk of an economic
recession especially member states
most affected by the lack of gas
exported by traditional suppliers
dramatic bills where
households are respected for electricity
and gas in
2023 and for sm visa
bills have skyrocketed up to 500 percent
if compared to
last year values
such
scenario means that besides reducing
consumption and keeping deposit fields
a new level cap
on gas prices is needed as already
requested by some member states while
the you must support the new domestic
drilling ventures as well as the
building of new infrastructure to ensure
the fast replacement of the missing gas
that
is usually needed by our industry and
consumers thank you very much
thank you so much paulo on behalf of ecr
mr tobiisovsky please
thank you chairman
thank you director
for your statement
i'd like to draw your attention to a
certain issue two years ago in the
autumn and winter commissioner simpson
and representatives of dg energy
stated that
the
gas market in the eu
was complete
the infrastructure is there
and all we need to do
they said back then
is to complete a certain project now it
turns out we have no interconnectors we
have no common market in place
and we only have
poorly connected islands so to speak now
we have to
suddenly and urgently build
interconnectors and other infrastructure
but now we are facing an unprecedented
crisis
and this crisis is still developing it's
a dynamic situation the prices of gas
are going up and
we have not yet come to the period when
uh we need to hit our houses so the
european commission
what are they recommending now
we have a problem with ets the price of
the price here is 80 euros
so
are we receiving any support or is this
current situation getting worse so we
need to suspend the ets it is our
committee
who appealed for the withdrawal of
financial institutions from this system
time is not on our side
so a priority now should be to make it
possible
for member states
to shape the energy mix
according to the resources that these
member states have there at their
disposal
since the common gas market does not
function does not exist in reality then
the member states should be able to make
use of the resources that they have at
their disposal because these resources
can fill
the gap
left by the shortages of gas we need to
make sure the citizens and the member
states are secure for the winter
we need to
provide security for the
european union in an effective way we
need to make the right diagnosis and
take the right decisions
at least on behalf of the left
side
thank you very much for the information
that you've given us so your proposal at
least outlines a scenario of savings and
the front of material reality we need
gas and we don't have it
um
it's possible to change the model
however and we can adopt a planned
strategy to reduce demand
um
but at the moment it doesn't look like
there's a balanced or fair approach i
think it's necessary to
accelerate a fair transition
and also put an end to
the process of marginal pricing
we need to understand the
strong dependence that we have on fossil
fuels at the moment and all this has
been exacerbated at the same time it's
necessary for the commission to
recognize its responsibility
in this energy model which has serious
flaws and it's allowed
energy oligopolies to develop in a
sector of such vital importance without
without appropriate controls
um
allowing
profits to explode
and um are
costing
consumers uh horrendous amounts we're
all aware of what's happening here it's
very
important essential indeed to plan
saving measures at the same time
we need a long-term plan
and
that requires
an underpinning of common sense and fair
and sustainable priorities
obviously all of this is only possible
with public oversight and a clear
planned strategy based on
the public interests and recognizing the
limits of the planet
this proposal
is still socially and environmentally
unfair so
my question is
is it a good idea to turn to fossil
fuels after a summer full of climate
events
would it not be
appropriate
for the commission to establish
mechanisms for public oversight and
transparency uh to identify the genuine
cost
uh 36 million people
are looking at not being able to heat
their homes and will there be measures
established in winter to um avoid that
figure accelerating
i go now to the
deputy director general to answer to all
these questions thank you very much mr
chair and thank you all for your very
important and relevant questions i will
try
to answer them maybe in blocks
so first of all
we have done indeed a lot i mean the
whole we power eu strategy
uh covers a number of areas where we are
continuing to work and as i uh already
said we have a number of already fast
track measures the storage filling or
and now the demand reduction for gas uh
really key example historically key
example
that we work in solidarity with our eu
member states and they are ready to
implement them so i think we have set up
also the energy platform
we are working on the joint purchasing
we have set up different regional groups
there was one in bulgaria there were
one in the northwest europe i chaired
the one in the south west europe and
there are also others in the central
eastern european countries which in
these regional groups we try to really
bundle the demand look at what is
necessary and then now prepare to do it
jointly so i think this is something we
continue and uh
are ready uh to engage uh also with the
parliament
and we have done also quite a lot and
that's part of we power on the savings
side which is important and on the
internal market so i think we are
continuing implementing it
there is a crisis now i think we are all
extremely aware and the energy prices
both gas and electricity are bills or
high we have never seen before there is
speculation there is uncertainty in the
market and that's why we are looking
even more intensively right now what
else needs to be done
which
we need to present and discuss with you
just coming first back to some of the
questions on interconnectors
we had the discussion on 10e
where we concluded in a long trial like
trial logs always are
that we don't finance any more gas
pipelines but that we concentrate on the
electricity with we power eu and the
situation we are now we
identified however some bottlenecks
where we are looking into it what's
needed to really connect everyone in the
new situation where gas flows are not
from east to west but west to east so we
are implementing that including looking
at hydrogen this is the future so we are
combining it and looking where it's
needed future gas which need to be
hydrogen ready or hydrogen dedicated
infrastructure so that's where we are
and we have six solidarity agreements
with eight countries right now and we
are encouraging countries to step that
up uh what much more
as i said and a lot of question about
the crisis right now there is more to
come we have an extraordinary or the
presidency
announced an extraordinary council of
energy ministers next friday already
so for that there is not
much we can prepare except some factual
updates and we will listen to our member
states what they are doing in gas and
electricity prices and what more in the
meantime as requested by the european
council already we are looking at price
caps and what is possible and we have
some technical seminars and exchanges so
there are different form of price caps
for example for import of gas from
russia there are price caps within the
eu that the wholesale price caps are the
retail market the retail price caps
which member states are already applying
so we are looking at all possibilities
full speed and that is what we want to
achieve also what is the feedback for
member states on all these questions
in particular on electricity prices
which we are also looking at short-term
measures emergency measures how can we
avoid these huge bills how can we
protect vulnerable consumers but not
only any more while normal consumers but
also
middle-income households or industries
we are hearing that as you do even more
what
we can do here so there will be work or
there is work on emergency measures on
electricity prices there might be also
something on demand reduction for
electricity we speak today about demand
reduction for gas it's obviously
very different
the gas and market and electricity
markets are very different you have gas
storage you have electricity uh
peaks or daily but no storage so it's a
different
type of action which we are looking at
and
medium to long term as it was asked we
are looking at our electricity market
design
it had worked well over the last decade
we have marginal pricing we are looking
at option to optimize it to reform it
but that takes time i can't or the
president wonderline couldn't promise
that for tomorrow but it's for sure that
we will do a proper impact assessment
stakeholder consultation involving
parliament
full and look at all options with a open
mind because we are in a very very
different situation uh now than we were
before
so all this is in the making and i'm
sure we are coming back we power you
already mentioned that there is a
possibility to look at windfall
taxes and and windfall prices to to look
at the benefits this is also in in the
pipeline uh what we are looking at so i
stop here there's a lot of work ongoing
and i'm sure we are also coming back
yes
indeed we have the second round now
as i
as always shorter interventions one
minute please colleagues and i start
the round with the intervention of
president buzak epp
thank you very much uh colleague
uh thank you madam
director general for your information
uh we should cooperate in excellent way
both our institutions so my first
question is about that because while the
working on the storage regulation
the european parliament was pushing for
some saving measures
and uh council commissioners said
it is not necessary it is not needed at
all so we were rather surprised
both institutions just few weeks later
agreed exactly on such measures
and um i would like to ask you
if
if
this regulation on gas reduction is to
be extended for another year
it will be done through the ordinary
legislative procedure or in the same way
we would like to be as close as possible
in the future
a second question very short
well
15 percent
where does this percentage come from a
few days ago we hear that member states
already achieved the target of 80
percent
in gas storage
congratulations fantastic
european parliament expected 90 they
were fighting for that
is another case so isn't this 15 percent
target also too conservative maybe thank
you
thank you president mr gonzalez
thank you and thank you for your
presentation
um
it's important
to recognize that we've been making
warnings about this over the last year
the commission was dragging its feet and
now we find ourselves in the situation
we're in and we need
responses that
meet the seriousness of the challenge
the final decision adopted in july
um i believe is the right one
but i want to ask you whether commission
has an estimation of what percentage of
savings can be made by member states
over this time
if we look at the design of the
electricity markets for a long time our
group has been putting forward
proposals to decouple prices
to
favor and promote renewables
now we're told
that
issues these issues are going to be
taken in
uh to account for the structural reform
uh which will take time but what about
the emergency reform
one thing i want to know is whether
iser has changed its position against
the reform
which has been a position that has been
static for months while the situation
has changed thank you very much
mr peterson the vice chair of the
committee
thanks so much uh christian and thanks
so much
mrs verstow for
for you being with us today i think we
all
realize how serious the situation we're
in and i think we all acknowledge and
appraise the hard work done by you and
your colleagues in in in the commission
now uh just a reflection on the point
made by our colleague ila previously on
on the need for deepening the markets
and cross-border issues i think it's a
extremely important point to make and
then we'll have to follow up
on this now on the window preparedness i
think it's extremely important that we
provide incentives for member states to
actually make savings because
if we end up in a situation where we
only subsidize further consumption we
will not get where we want to get to
ensure full independency from russia
and and
just a reminder to this house and this
committee on ourselves we have important
files on the table this fall on
efficiency directive and on buildings
directive that we have to ensure high
ambitions on these files in order to
ensure namely the the independency from
from russia so we also have our own
responsibility in in
in this on on the electricity market
issues
i'd like to push you a little mo on
timeline on this because uh obviously
this is of of critical importance so
you're referring to an impact assessment
i guess
the outcome of this depends on on what
you're assessing uh so i'd be curious to
to to have a little further information
on this i think
sorry just to mention the stability
issues i mean we have investors out
there wanting to spend billions on
projects they need stability so that has
to be factored in thank you thank you so
much more than mrs carvalho vice
coordinator of epp
thank you chair thank you madame
director general and thank you for your
intervention however i was
a bit disappointed with your
intervention we live as you said in
times of crisis and we need
important
emergency and also structural reforms
and i had a lot of hope
with the
words of the president vanderlian in the
beginning of this week so i was
expecting that you give us more at least
the line that you because the president
has said you are working commissioner is
already working so
the main lines that you are working how
parliament is going to be involved and
the timetable because some of the
measures need to be urgent so if you
could share these details with us i
would appreciate thank you very much
thank you so much mrs paulus the greens
sorry i have to search for the button
thank you martin for your words i
couldn't agree more um on prices i think
cupping prices in wholesale or retail
markets will just lead to taxpayers
money being funneled into fossil gas
produces already building pockets as
price is simply inelastic in a time of
limited supply and right now we're more
or less um
keeping the prices up in competition
with asia where the markets are reacting
to what europe is doing of course
um i would like to know
what which options does the commission
mull over concerning the reform of the
electricity market because i do agree
that marginal pricing is not a suitable
market design in a system which is
dominated by renewables because prices
will become negative in times of high
supply
and hydrogen plants covering the
residual load in times of low supply
will presumably only run less than 1 000
hours a year so they would need
extremely high prices to cover their
fixed costs and i don't think that this
is sustainable but i would caution
caution against going back to a
regulated system because this would
disincentivize investment and renewables
in storage and might even hamper the
transition as you can observe in texas
right now where a new gas plant is built
instead of expanding the grid thank you
so much
mr guyer
thank you president
then
thank you chairman
the colleagues have put some pressing
questions
when it comes to the commission's
uh preparation
for the
energy summit and mrs first offer i
would endorse those questions now i
understand that you can't
tell us
about all of your
plans the president of the commission
will do that but please give us an
indication
of which direction
you're heading in i think that's
something we would all
welcome
i think
there's just a couple of points i would
like to add to the arguments that used
by my colleagues
we're
not at war luckily
on the 1st of
september
is the day when nazi germany invaded
poland and started the second world war
and i think it's good that we can sit
here together peacefully and work on
solutions together but our economy of
course is affected by the consequences
of war
and
given that that's the case we need to
give some thought to
how we can react uh
to these measures and i think mrs van
der leyen
was very courageous but it was still a
bit vague so i think we need to have
some greater clarity now
we need to make it through winter of
course
and if i
hear uh about the lights being switched
off because of gas imports the lack
thereof but uh
we also of course need to prepare for
the winter of 2324. from ib
i have another look thank you chair i
will speak in dutch um
[Music]
there are colleagues who insist
uh
on investing in unreliable energy
sources such as wind and solar and have
been moving away from reliable
sources and that the crisis we're in are
the result of those choices your choices
and
now you want to save
gas for a safe winter that's a report
that was leaked and it has a
recommendation to stop the phasing out
of nuclear energy
and they also say that we should shift
towards nuclear energy to reduce our gas
consumption but
question one why is the commission uh
ceded to the ideological pressure from a
minority and why has the recommendation
been removed from the definitive version
that was published of the report it's
time for the commission to shoulder its
responsibilities vis-a-vis the citizens
and to stop phasing out nuclear energy
then solidarity solidarity plays a key
role in the energy uh community in the
eu
and the essence of the regulation
save gas for a safer winter is
underpinned by that
but
if
germany takes the questionable decision
to close its last three reactors i don't
want to have to explain to the dutch why
out of solidarity they should be paying
more for their energy
please
foreign thank you
the failure of the
energy market is a financial problem
primarily we have tools to deal with it
we should immediately freeze ets prices
to save the producers of energy and the
entire industry european commission
it seems prefers to freeze the citizens
rather than admit to
a mistake
it seems that the worst problem of
europe
in the face of this crisis is the
arrogance of
europe's leaders
in the parliament and in the european
commission there is no political will
to
make an effective correction of the
evidently
wrong energy policy
we are like the titanic
which is heading full steam ahead
facing a catastrophe the difference is
that the
captain of the titanic did not know
what's in front of him you however know
exactly what we are facing but you don't
want to correct the course
at all
in the name of ambitions
but
this will be a price that will have to
be paid by millions of europeans so do
we need the catastrophe for the european
leaders to wake up
love icpp
thank you so much i have one short
question on energy efficiency and one on
nuclear um on energy efficiency is the
commission considering measures to boost
behavioral changes in europe uh for all
citizens even more than already touched
upon
and initiated that could be support
tools for member states but also eu-wide
campaigns so that also the european
institutions are reaching out to smes
and families and helping them to do what
they really want to do
on nuclear we are currently see how the
use of
coal is rising significantly and we see
how price caps in some countries result
in increasing economic support for
highly emitting power plants at the same
time we see an extreme shortage of
nuclear energy from france
what opportunities do we have in europe
to increase the energy from nuclear on a
short-term basis thank you so much yes i
did it
thank you so much bernie thank you for
being extremely on time i have four
requests for hdie but
i said the beginning that it will be
very challenging we still have some time
if you can do it in 30 seconds just one
question then
but please it is a little bit so mrs
piragi mr kelin patricia toya my sister
and mr kav
mrs
30 seconds uh mrs spiraki first
one question
thank you very much
director general i would like to further
to elaborate further to mr modern
paterson question on the issue of the
pricing model because we are focusing
the danger of political reformation and
instability in our countries due to the
the the populist so i would like to ask
you how fast do you go on on the issue
of this impact assessment what kind of
assessment will it will take place and
how fast you will implement the new
model
thank you patricia
just one very quick question
and i can endorse what colleagues have
said but why why why
there's
not a great deal of transparency
when it it comes to how prices are set
you yourself said there's little
transparency now for months we've been
asking for the commission
to tell us about this
and we've also asked other commissioners
to speak to this
and there's not really a lot of
information forthcoming now if the lack
of transparency is affecting families
and our industry we have a duty
to lift the veil and look what's beneath
please
much appreciated mr german compliments
to the commission on their efforts to
try and alleviate the situation which we
find ourselves in
but i just want to ask one question
in my country we are heavily dependent
on gas but the policy is it's great to
use the gas once it doesn't come from
ireland
and have the commission aware of the
fact that we have a policy of keep it in
the ground that we have vast reserves of
gas
off the west coast of the carob and very
raw
but because of this policy introduced a
number of years ago we are not utilizing
it and this i think is unfair to the
european union who are doing everything
they can to source cats from around the
world thank you very much thank you so
much
thank you i would like to elaborate a
bit on uh about the industrial side of
things and the facts of possible cuts of
energy consumption on the price of basic
goods we know that the unbearable energy
costs that have been spiraling in the
past months are leading to many
undertakings either going bankrupt or
having a difficult situation or um
increasing their prices and at the end
of the day there's a domino effect with
skyrocketing prices for basic goods this
is about
protecting jobs but also consumer prices
affordable consumer prices and that's
why i'd like to ask if the commission is
ready to face this possible domino
effect and which are the concrete
actions it envisages to undertake in
order to protect enterprises income
statement but also the purchasing power
of european consumers thank you thank
you so much the very last mr kiran
thank you very much mr chair in a crisis
we must act decisively and good work has
been done under the repower eu
initiative but we must not delay we must
speed up the clean energy transition and
martin is right we need increased
ambition on the epbd
but energy poverty is real and will get
worse this winter
so is it not time for an energy crisis
fund at eu level to tackle the cost of
living and the climate crisis funded
from a windfall tax from oil and gas
company profits thank you thank you so
much kieran
deputy director general really
challenging a lot a lot of questions but
the situation is very very challenging
also
thank you very much and i'm sure we we
will have ample uh um occasions to to go
deeper and
the president founderline will give
the 14th of september the state of the
union and i can assure you there will be
a lot on energy and we will follow up uh
or we are already preparing and follow
up that
very very intensively and you are very
much right the situation we are right
now uh both on the gas prices but also
electricity price security of supply
concern is of the highest concern and
priority in the commission so we are
coming back to many of those questions
but i will try obviously to cover what i
can right now
so thank you very much mr buzak on all
your input and leading on on on the gas
storage uh and what we can do
the regulation which we proposed on the
20th of july we had proposed two years
the council decided on one year we have
to see what's happening in one year but
what more can we do uh when we maybe are
a bit out of the crisis even though i
agree to what was said it's not this
winter it's the coming winters where we
need to cover uh the situation
but
we will involve the parliament extremely
closely and the question of 15 demand
reduction if it's too conservative
if we have now an eu average of storage
of 80 it's reinsuring for this winter
but uh we can face a cold winter and we
need to continue and have the feeling of
gas storage in march
at a certain percentage i think it's 40
percent to be able for the winter 20 30
23 24. so this is a continuous exercise
where we need to look at and that's why
we have
a voluntary demand reduction target of
15 percent but if needed we go to the
mandatory and that's why uh the
continuous efforts for the winters to
come is needed
very rightly so a number of you
mentioned uh we power and the need to
keep the ambitious of eppd ed and ret ii
and we are very very ready to engage
with you the trilogs are coming up uh
under czech presidency and we will keep
that in mind it's a top priority as well
to to have the highest possible
ambition there as you know we power in
may added proposals legal proposals on
permitting raise the 45 percent
renewables target and
we are keeping a close eye also on epbd
what's needed and energy efficiency
savings so i i can only underline the
importance of that as well
also um the same for
infrastructure and cross-border it was
mentioned a few days ago we inaugurated
a connection poland slovakia and in
in the end of september there will be
the baltic interconnector from pollock
poland to the baltics country so we are
paying off what we worked on for the
last 10 years with the pcis and saf
funding they are more and more
interconnection of in the gas market and
electricity market
lng terminals and and so on but with the
crisis obviously we need to look at
bottlenecks and what needs to be further
strengthened but just to underline that
a couple of these projects which takes
years and years to be already right now
in time for the winter
as the baltic interconnector as an
example
of all that
coming back to the issue of prices and
as i said
mrs fondaline our president will outline
that in more detail
on the 14th of september so in two weeks
we are working on emergency measures we
are well aware that the prices as i said
also before
are affecting vulnerable consumers so we
need to help them member states are
already doing quite a lot and we
encourage them to do more
but there is not anymore as i said the
issue of vulnerable but also
middle-income household and industry so
we are
looking our
current security of supply regulation
covers protected customers we have
something in place
what need to be do
we are looking at the issue of critical
industry which is not covered in the
current security of supply regulation
and they are coming to see you and us so
we are looking and member states are
preparing energy
intensive industry we met aluminium
fertilizers and many more who are
extremely struggling with the high
energy prices in addition to the
vulnerable and other consumers so we are
looking in what is needed also for those
critical consumers which
as our security of supplier regulation
is not apt for a crisis we are in right
now so we need to look what we can
demand what we can add and we are right
now doing that as well
uh
i i don't come back on the issue of
price caps because that is something we
are looking at the european council
asked us so we are
offering options we will listen
listening first to the extraordinary
energy council on the 7th of september
but then we will also come up uh also
after the speech of miss van der line
and discussions with the european
parliament on what are the concrete
options also for the reform of the
market design
[Music]
which the marginal prices we know
we are working as i said on more
deployment of renewables we need to
integrate them and we need to reform our
market design we are well aware of that
but just let to underline it can't be
overnight but we are looking at all the
options even wider than we had maybe
done
uh when we started looking at what we
can do to avoid what the situation we
are on it's partly speculation but it's
also partly demand and supply and we are
working as i said on the supply side
and it's not only on third countries we
are looking and we power eu mentioned
domestic production
so this is also up then to the member
states to look at domestic production
but also then imports from third country
when it comes to the energy mix and
nuclear this is something member states
are looking at we know this summer and
that has also um
aggravated the crisis we are in there
were a couple of factors
which
really made it even worse so the nuclear
situation in france where half of the
capacity is for different reasons in
maintenance there are corrosion issues
and others which france is tackling
right now there's the
very dry summer which has put a lot of
problems on hydropower certainly in
portugal and spain and france and other
parts of europe and that is in the
situation we are already quite
adding to the problems and and the price
situation we are so we have to work on
all that short term temporary solutions
member states are taking is looking at
at coal and other means but we are
committed medium and long term and as
you know uh on as i said before on the
european green deal fit for 55 and all
the proposal we need uh to continue
i
think
uh i stopped here there were many more
questions i'm sure
um yes there was one and that was the
last question we are launching a
campaign
uh in september um
together with our press department or dg
communication on energy savings i think
we did already together with the
international energy agency some 10
points plan to save gas and oil we will
continue that or upgrade that member
states are already
doing some so we are collecting best
practice we can only encourage to do
that we will use social media and all
that and if the you are very well placed
uh to to highlight that
i think it is a step a needed step in
addition to all the other steps we need
to take so we can achieve also issues uh
savings from behavioral and other
measures i stop here i'm sure we will
come back and i would like to thank you
all for all the interesting questions
thank you so much indeed madam deputy
director general verdur
thank you for your presence thank you
for answering to
most of the questions and also giving us
very important and relevant information
of course we'll all follow the
initiative of european commission we'll
look closely to the decisions of the
extraordinary energy ministers council
of the next friday and we'll stay in
close contact with our commissioner and
with dgner and once again thank you for
the very good dialogue and cooperation
and please understand
the urgency and the need to maybe change
a little bit some paradigms and
see what are the solutions in order to
help european citizens and industries
once again thank you so much
dear colleagues
because
many of you just joined the meeting i
would like
once again to wish you
a lot of success in your work
this
this autumn it is
it is indeed a very challenging time an
italian committee will be